Hello, everyone. Welcome.
And thanks for joining us on this special edition of the tight rope today's
episode is in partnership with intelligence squared.
I'm Trisha Rose here with my co-host and friend Cornell West today's
episode of the tightrope is what they call a takeover of the intelligence
squared podcast. For those of you who don't know them,
intelligence squared is a leading forum for discussion and debate with high
profile guests from around the world. So if you're watching or listening this,
listening to this on the tightrope,
check out the intelligence squared podcast and the YouTube channel.
And if you found us through intelligence squared,
please take a look at the links to the tie robes podcast,
and channels in the description and subscribe
today's guest is Minnesota Congresswoman Ilhan, Omar.
She represents Minnesota's fifth congressional district,
which includes the city of Minneapolis before becoming a Congress woman.
Two years ago,
she was an experienced twin city policy analyst and community organizer.
She's one of only two Muslim American women elected to Congress,
the first Somali American member of Congress and the first woman of color to
represent Minnesota representative. Omar. Thank you for joining us.
Welcome to the tight rope.
It is an honor to be here with you today.
We're, we're thrilled to have you, I just want to start off.
I know we don't have a lot of time with you today and I just want to just start
off with, you know, how you're doing, how your family's doing.
I know everyone's wondering, you know, you're running around on the trail,
but also how's your constituencies doing what what's on the ground,
where things are right now. Yeah.
We're all holding on. Um, you know,
I represent a district that includes all of Minneapolis and
14 other surrounding municipalities. And as many of you know,
Minneapolis has been ground zero for, um,
the response our communities have had to police brutality after the murder of
George Floyd in the hands of the Minneapolis police. Um,
and so there's a lot of trauma that has been an earth. There was a lot of pain.
Uh, people were already struggling because of the public health pandemic and the
financial crisis that it brought. And, uh, and now,
you know, there's, there's just a lot of other pain, um,
that people are going through, but were resilient here in Minneapolis. Uh,
and we are, um,
a community that's Rives on solidarity. And so we have been, um,
holding onto one another and helping each other through not just depend
emic, but the financial crisis. And now, you know,
dealing with systematic racism and police brutality.
Yeah. Well, you've got your hands full.
And deed. Well, we are just so blessed to have you with us.
It's so wonderful to have somebody who's so courageous and so
consistent and so compassionate when it comes to the least
of these in the biblical sense of the ones catching halo,
press folk here and around the world.
How do you read this present moment though? I mean,
we've got this kind of Neo fascism escalating.
We need to push the gangster out of the white house.
And yet at the same time we've got the contestation among the
coalition itself. Well, how do you read this moment?
Yeah, I mean, we have to remember right. That we didn't,
we didn't arrive in this moment by accident, uh,
everything that we are living through and,
you know, thinking of as a, as a painful moment in our history,
um, was ushered in, by, you know,
decades of social and economic neglect,
uh, by systems that weren't designed for many of us to, um,
not survive and thrive. Um,
and you know, we have had, um,
decaying really of our systems of
democracy, um, and,
and our morality, uh,
that has led its way into allowing someone
like the president that we currently have to come to
power. And, you know, I was, I was, uh,
reminiscing about, you know, my,
my arrival here in the United States.
And I was thinking about how my father would have
reacted. If someone told him that, you know,
some day we would have a president unhinged enough to,
um, to use his daughter's name and every rally and,
uh, and, and conversation to stare up hate,
but that also the American people would vote for someone who would not
only neglect to fully address a public health crisis, uh,
address, you know, an economic crisis.
That's bringing on devastation onto people,
but would take joy in an earth thing,
um,
trauma for people and sort of thriving in,
in dividing our nation and not, um,
uniting it. And, and I said, you know, my dad would have,
uh, told him to seek help.
I think, you know, to, to many of we are,
we continue to be stuck in this moment where, um,
w we're we're analyzing this situation from a
decency point of view, right? Like, how did we get here?
How would our country, our fellow country,
men and women would allow someone like this president to come
to power. Um,
but if you look at the, the complacency, um,
that has been part of our systems for so
long, for so many people, it's not that surprising.
There isn't that much to analyze. Um,
we haven't invested in strengthening our communities.
We haven't invested in the strengthening, our democracy.
We haven't invested in making a representative democracy actually
represent its people. And we haven't invested in having,
you know, the mechanisms to allow, um,
for government to be of,
of the people and for the people. And so now,
do we not only have, you know, uh,
fascism at our doorsteps, but we also have, uh,
a system that is for the first time, I would say,
in the open, um,
sort of wrapping the American people and, you know,
every single day somebody says, why can't you hold them accountable?
Why isn't this administration accountable? Um,
and we can't because we haven't really invested in strengthening
our accountability measures, um,
to stop someone from exploiting them.
Hmm. Yeah. Yeah. You know what you say there, um,
really puts into more into broader context of the crisis that
we're facing regarding not just the moment,
but this legacy of neglect and this legacy of, of certain kinds of,
of racialized corruption in particular. So it may,
I'm wondering if you could focus this, uh, uh,
issue in on, um,
George Floyd and all of the institutional mechanisms and systemic forces that
you described, uh, that you referenced, you know,
that brought him into the situation he was in because, you know,
some conservatives and others might say, you know, listen,
it's a democratic leader. And in the town where I, uh, the district was,
um, uh, a democratic district, you know, how is it that, um,
this could happen to George Floyd in, in what would be considered, uh,
you know, a relatively liberal context, but can you,
can you unpack what you were just saying in relation to that,
because I think people need to hear why this isn't just a matter of,
of individual institutions being able to respond to those kinds of
crisis.
Yeah. I mean, we, we are seeking to have, um,
equal access to systems that were created without us in
mind. Um,
and so it doesn't really matter the amount of
reforms we carry on.
If the whole system is sort of designed
to not grant you,
access to opportunity and prosperity access to
your civil liberties, access to your full humanity,
access to dignity. You know, people think of Minnesota as a,
as a liberal Haven. Um, and it is for, for a lot of people.
Uh, but it's also one of the worst States for black people to live in.
Um,
every single study has shown that Minnesota,
Wisconsin, and Illinois, um,
are the worst three seats for black people to live. Uh,
and that's, that's not because the, you know,
the people in power haven't done the work of trying to reform
these systems is that the systems themselves didn't imagine people
like us living here, um,
and didn't create systems to fully
allow us to exist as ourselves fully equal to everyone
else. Um,
and so you will see the disparities because, you know,
they, the systems aren't designed to educate our children,
the systems aren't designed to create economic investment in our communities,
the systems aren't designed, um,
to adequately absorb us in, into,
into society. And, you know, the,
the kind of transformation that is needed, um, is,
is asking people to do something that they haven't done before.
And there is, um, fear, uh,
amongst many,
because their way of life feels threatened when you are asking for
them to, you know, expand their,
their thought process and to reimagine a system where everybody's
way of life is protected and uplifted.
Mm Hmm. Yeah. You know, it just strikes me that one of the, uh,
historically unique callings that you have,
and haven't been able to execute in such a powerful way,
is to try to convince folk on the ground that that
system was not designed for them. So I'm with like Martin Luther King,
you call for revolution,
fundamental change in priority shift of power and wealth from
those at the top to everyday people.
But you also are able to do that inside of the very system itself.
So you've got this inside,
outside dialectical dance that is so difficult
to do. How do you pull that off monsters?
Yeah. I mean, you know, I'm, I'm an organizer.
And so, um, having, having that mindset,
um, and bringing that in into the halls of power has allowed me to
not forget right, who, who I work for,
where I came from,
what it felt like to be out
protesting and organizing people, um,
to see themselves as not only part of the system,
but to see themselves as agents of change. Uh,
and now that, that I am there, that's,
that's the only way I can see myself. And, you know, if,
if we think about what Martin Luther King was fighting for and how he
transformed, you know,
even his messaging after the civil rights battle was won
was to, to speak about, there is no good at right,
like having equality when he said, you know, what, what,
what is it to have a seat at the table if you can't like,
what is it to have a seat at the counter, if you can buy the burger, um,
is to, to understand that, you know, I don't,
I don't just want you to see me as equal.
I also want you to see me as deserving of equal
opportunity and prosperity and, you know, um,
everything that, that is part of the promise of America.
Um, and so, so for many of us,
we recognize that our cries in the streets can
be legislated, right. And we can,
in the ways in which they have codified profit
for, um,
corporations and prioritizing capitalist
society,
we can codify our opportunities for
prosperity into, into law as well.
We can quantify our, um,
right to wealth and joy and dignity and humanity. Uh,
and I know that, um, that's a great task, but we are,
we are, we are up to it. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. You are up to it. That is for sure. Um, but what,
what are some of the obstacles that may also be inside the
democratic party? Right. Um,
it's easy in these highly polarized voting president presidential
election contexts to think of it simply between two parties, but,
you know, if I knew it as the white house, uh,
and Democrats win the house in the Senate, you know,
do you think that there'll be enough groundswell within the context of the
democratic party to embrace the kinds of progressive
visions for, um, the kinds of opportunity that you just described?
Uh, yes and no. Um,
I know that, you know, there, there is going to be, um,
a cohort with,
within the democratic caucus, um, in, in Congress,
whether it's in the Senate or in the house,
that really is clear-eyed about what our objectives are in addressing,
you know, the, the,
the decades of social and economic neglect that many of our communities
have experienced that have brought us to this moment.
And I've been laid bare by, by the public health crisis.
Um, but I also know that, you know, what we are seeking to do,
um, hasn't been done before and we will be faced with
many obstacles and a lot of people will try
to go back to their traditional conversations
about incremental change. And, you know, we,
we can't move fast enough.
We can dream big enough and we can't implement, you know,
transformative change,
but what we are mobilizing for right now,
isn't just to, to,
to sustain the house and when the Senate and the white house,
but it's to keep up the momentum, um,
on the ground, uh, because we are,
we're going to need an organized electorate in order
to have sustainable change.
Mm Hmm. I mean,
I think part of the challenge is how do you get a democratic
party where its major corporate wing is so tied to wall
street and Pentagon militarism the focus on
the predatory capitalism on the one hand and that militarism abroad the
groans and Somalia and Yemen and so forth. And,
and at the same time deal with the white supremacy and male supremacy at home,
the homophobia and transphobia at home.
Now you have been able to speak with carriage to each one of those
issues. That that's a rare thing for elected officials. I know I don't,
I don't want to just keep coming back to that point, but my dear sister,
that's her red thing, and it needs to be said and acknowledged that highlighted.
And yet you got to walk your own tight rope and we glad to have you on our tap
room, but, but you get,
you got to walk your own tight rope daily and you've been able to do it so well.
And we just wonder, it's hard to say how that's going to going to unveil.
We've got to get the gangster out of the white house first. That's, that's,
that's the crucial thing right now,
but after I think it is going to be a battle and one, one does,
how does it go into a procedural? You know?
Yeah. I mean, so I will say, you know,
I think one of the most threatening things about me to,
to not just the right, um, but to the establishment at large,
is,
is that the unique lens that I bring as someone
who has lived outside of the United States, who had, uh,
a window to the school of America,
um, and who now lives in America and is an American, um,
who gets to see the soul of America from a different
point of view, um, is that I,
I know how we see ourselves and I know that how other people see
us, and there is a clear gap,
uh, and most of us have values and principles
that don't allow us to want that gap to exist.
And I think the awakening of, of that consciousness, um,
is really what has made me a threat
to, to, to the powers that be, um,
because it is an important awakenness that needs to happen.
People have to be awakened from the
complacency of believing,
right? That,
that everything that we are doing outside of this country,
that we seem to think is done out of a humanitarian,
um, point of view,
isn't being viewed that way to the people we are trying to be,
um, you know, responsive to and, and supportive to. And if,
if we want that value to be carried out on those principles to be carried out,
then we have to change the way that we carry out our missions
of, um, of, of,
of foreign engagement and, you know, domestically,
I think a lot of people also, you know, I know you talk about this, Mr. West.
Um, often I know Bernie, um,
talks about this often is that we don't make a clear
connection,
but the economic devastations that we are living here in here in the United
States, and those, the least of us, um,
are bearing the burden of that economic devastation.
And every time they ask for, you know,
a cancellation of student debt, or they asked for, um,
an increase in the minimum wage, or they ask for, you know,
a housing program that, that ends our homelessness,
or they ask for more support for our veterans who are living on the side of the
streets, people say, or even, you know, addressing our climate crisis.
People say, how can we afford it, right. Um, how are we going to pay for it?
And there,
that conversation never takes place when it comes to our supporting our endless
Wars, it never comes to, you know,
the billions of dollars we shell out every single year, um,
to,
to the Pentagon those conversations aren't asked when we are talking
about what defending our country looks like,
but our defense is also domestic.
And if we are to invest, uh,
in creating a stronger society, um,
that, that would ultimately make us safer,
uh, and would lead to, you know,
a more prosperous United States. You know, it is,
it's almost ironic and laughable that there are so many people who are
coming out on an America first, um,
banner and rhetoric who are not interested
in investing in raising the minimum wage are not invested
in addressing our climate crisis are not invested in ending.
Homelessness are not invested in, you know, stopping wall street,
um, from robbing, you know, the American people blind or not invested in,
you know, stopping these endless Wars and, you know, the, the Bloomington,
the bloating of the Pentagon budget. Um,
and you know,
the way that we get to do what you asked earlier, um,
is, is by continuing to emphasize that, you know, and,
and sending out that message to the American people,
that our work has always been about putting people
first, and, you know,
the people who are telling you that we are some how
radical for wanting to feed our children and how's our,
um, folks and, you know,
create a livable planet, um,
are the ones that are not putting America first and are not,
are not the ones that are putting your lives first. Um, well,
wow, well put.
Very much so, um,
I know you have a hard stop and so we don't want to hold you up,
especially because we know you're going off to do good things,
and we hope your family stays safe and that, um, and that, you know,
with the last few days on this trail are treat you well.
And we really hope you join us again on the tie rope. And, uh,
we're also sharing this space with intelligence squared.
So we welcome you back to, uh, either venue in the future.
And we thank you again for joining us here on the tightrope today.
Yeah, well, we know that Ilana means beautiful voice,
powerful voice.
The Negro Nasser Anthem is lift every voice as a prosthetic Muslim
voice and the legacy of Malcolm X and Hammad Ali, and so many others,
we salute you and we are with you. Thank you.
Boy, Cornell. That was an amazing conversation with representative Omar.
She is just a force for good and such an inspiration.
She's got a powerful intellect.
She's got a strong spirit and a compassionate heart. She really does.
Well. My dear colleague Cornell, this is the end of our office hours,
which is always a sad thing, but we'll have more. So that's, that's an upside.
And we're also delighted to have been able to be part of a
takeover with intelligence squared.
And so we wish them well and hope we can partner again in the future,
but we want to also ask our fans from the tie rope to go visit intelligence
squared and sign up. They have some fantastic debates, uh,
globally subjects of great interest.
And we want to tell you intelligent squared fans to come join us on the
tightrope. We got a safety net for you. I promise. And we have, uh,
equally rich dialogues on our, on our show.